Today, even with the most advanced advertising systems that exist,...
...they only have estimates of what someone's gender might be...
...or what someone's age might be or what they might be interested in.
But on Facebook, we know exactly what gender someone is.
And exactly how old they are, and exactly what they're interested in.
At a presentation to advertisers in 2007,...
Mark Zuckerberg pitched the benefits of Facebook's vast database.
When you run ads on Facebook,...
...you're also gonna learn a lot about the audience that you're reaching.
And a lot of this you're gonna be able to do directly...
...to the messages that you send to them and the content that they upload.
But the rest, we're gonna do...
...by aggregating nonpersonal identifiable information about the users that you're reaching.
Facebook's lifeblood and the heart of its revenue model...
...is the accumulation of data its users volunteer, including their interests or likes.
Advertisers, who helped boost Facebook's revenue...
...to an estimated 1.4 billion dollars in 2010,...
...buy access to that gold mine of anonymous demographic information,...
...enabling them to reach a remarkably specific and well targeted audience.